Surprises comes true sometimes
it's up on the screen what happens here
you can have a good time
Jon Bernthal, he plays the Punisher
yeah
Jon what's up what you doing here
you're not this is like you
it's scheduled to be here there's like
what are you doing here
click your display
yeah i just don't like everybody
cheering great school
okay well I'm trying to do the show like
I don't know I don't know
yeah
that you just show
just
does anybody want to see the trailer for
the beginning
yeah
thank you John thank you sir
what's the San Diego
I can you just give it up real quick for
the professor the man makes it all
happen mr. Jeff lobe real quick
we obviously have a chance to talk in
front of this group so either just I i
know that you stopped by because I know
you're making a movie right now which
accounts for all this stuff that's going
on with you
I so we appreciate you coming by tell me
until them out what was it like when you
you found out that you were going to
play Frank Castle on daredevil season
two
look II know you know I i I've said it
before I know how much she means to you
guys and I i take that with me every day
and and I know how much this character
matters I know how much he means to
members of the military to law
enforcement and I take it as an enormous
responsibility an enormous honor and I'm
eternally grateful
yeah
so you play the part
you can't walk down the street anymore i
mean people knew your shame before but
now on something else I don't know what
that is but but now you're Frank Castle
tell me at how has your life changed in
in that way or is that the reason why I
grew the beard in your hair is long and
always happy and he's in a suit
look I i think that you know the Marvel
fans and comic book fans the greatest
fans in the world and you know again
it's a lie i can't tell you how how
grateful I am for the the feedback but
you know Frank is he's he's in my he's
in my bones now he's with me so I think
if anything it just makes me you know
love my family harder
squeeze my kids harder and I think of
anything I just grateful for every day
and and again just enormously enormously
grateful for this opportunity and and
while everybody here may not believe us
that the truth is that we had we were
hopeful that when we started daredevil
that that we would be able to make a
very special phone call to you which was
to tell you that we are now going to go
into production on a Punisher series on
deck
yeah
what what was that day like when you
found out you now we're gonna have your
own show
time to get going you know get it right
work work work work in you know
yeah it's a same answer me
every floor I'm ready you know it's hot
all right i I really John seriously just
came by to say hello
I just it can everyone please thank you
for my way on new cage looks very very
good y'all
this is going to be that I mean I am
very very excited i hope you are excited
as i am there back there and oh man oh
man
Luke Cage
yeah